euh on parlait de la manifestation hier
euh pour prop palestinienne et qui s'est
très bien passé apparemment Gill et on
parlait de ce qui avait fait parler euh
parce que un moment les manifestants
ontandé allah akbar et c'est vrai que
voilà nous on disait ici que ça nous
dérangeait pas euh voilà Jacques toi tu
et Jean-Michel aussi ça ça te dérange tu
vas nous dire pourquoi moi ça moi je je
trouvais pas ça dérangeant et je vais
vous lire les alors bizarrement je suis
allé sur Wikipédia euh et ils disent
voilà que cette formule bien entendu euh
elle est elle a été utilisée dans le
cadre de mouvement de contestation
sociale et politique comme pendant la
Révolution iranienne le printemps arabe
ou le Mouvement Vert enfin peut
également servir de CR de guerre ou de
CR de victoire selon certains auteurs
elle était déjà un slogan de guerre du
temps de mahomé qu'il aurait lui-même
utilisé lors de la bataille de en 624
ainsi comme le notre pierre laoris la
formule est reprise par les musulmans et
par les musulmans radicaux oui ou je
vais pas laisser Jacques tout seul en
campagne comme ça parce que ça serait
hypocrite hypocrite de ma part parce que
je suis entièrement d'accord avec lui
dans le sens que évidemment que je ne
dis pas que c'est pas un message qui est
employé dans bien d'autres termes que
dans les termes qu'on connaît
malheureusement qui sont gravissimes
mais pour les non mususulmans on
l'entend comme ça et a partir moment eux
ils le crient comme ça sur la place
publique ils savent très bien qu'ils
s'adressent pas ils s'adressent il sont
pas en train de se parler à eux-mêmes
ils sont en train de s'adresser à la
population entière à une population non
musulmane qui elle ne le connaît que
dans ce contexte là donc à partir moment
on le connaît que dans ce contexte là on
ne peut l'accepter que dans ce sens là
et du coup c'est un peu gênant ça ne
peut passer que pour un un message un
peu de révolte de vengeance et cetera
même si c'est un message qui d'habitude
peut être employé dans d'autres termes
moi d'entend allahakbar quand il y a des
gens dans la rue qui entendent quelqu'un
écrire alakbar ils disent pas tiens il
est en train de fêter quelque chose ils
appelle la police en disant quelqu'un
qui crie à lacb dans la rue donc c'est
bien quelque part qu'on ne ressent pas
comme ça désolé l'expression a été
détourné par le terrorisme et vous en
faites une généralité vous la supprimé
la supprimé de la vie quotidien
Mo j'en ai un peu marre moi je vais vous
dire j'en a un peu Mar mais j'en ai un
peu marre parce que il devient de plus
en plus compliqué d'être musulman
aujourd'hui franchement mais je dis je
vous le dis on a l'impression que
maintenant quand on va à la mosquée il
faut se cacher quand on dit salam alkoum
on est en garde à vue quand on ditbar
maintenant on est un dangereux
terroriste encore quoi
encorei je vais
dire il l
ils prient s'ils ont envie de prier ils
mais laissez-moi finir merde ils ont
envie ils ont envie ils sont intégrés à
la société française ils prient quand
ils ont envie ils ramènent leur religion
qui est une religion de l'intime et moi
je dénonce de toutes mes forces ici
depuis des années la haine des Juifs et
je voudrais aussi aujourd'hui qu'on
dénonce la haine des musulmans parce que
là on est en train de stigmatiser des
millions de Français en leur disant vous
criez à Akbar ce qui est l'expression de
leur vie quotidienne bordel je sais pas
comment le dire mieux arrêtez arrêtez de
taper en permanence sur les 6 millions
de musulmans qui sont tranquilles et qui
ont envie de vivre bien dans la société
française voilà ce que je voulais dire
excusez-moi d'avoir été véhément mais
c'est très difficile aujourd'hui c'est
très difficile c'est très difficile là
rien trop difficile ouais sur sur ça non
non non mais arrêtez de
rigolerich s' vous plaît rigole parce
que je déteste ce genre de discours
c'est facile ils ont le droit de
travailler est-ce qu'on a dit le
contraire ils ont le droit de prier
est-ce qu'on a dit contraire
pas deourner le discours
deirev des
Bour tuis grand
numé détez vous stigmatisez les
musulmans moi je supporte pas ça moi je
vais te dire je supporte pas ça je
m'interroge sur 4000 personnes qui
chantent un cri qui est un cri de
terroriste et qui à chaque fois qu'il
passe à l'AE crib il y a encore cet
après midi un gamin de 15 ans devant une
synagogue à Strasbourg qu'on a surpris
avec un couteau dans la main en train de
crier Allah Akbar on l'a même pas vu
dans les journaux je vais te dire parce
que c'est tous les jours donc je
m'interroge sur les motivations de ces
4000 et ça m'empêche pas de te dire que
j'aime les musulmans que j'ai aucun
problème avec aucune des religions et
qu'il faut arrêter systématiquement
lorsqu'il s'agit de prendre la défense
des musulmans de dire que tous les
autres sont des
fach les gars il faut faut arrêter aussi
g Gilles il est aussi euh il est le le
porte-parole aussi de plein de gens qui
ont le même sentiment que Gilles g il
dit pas il dit pas
ça c'est pas c'est pas il est pas c'est
pas un cas isolé Gill il y en a plein
qui me disent ça moi j'ai j'ai plein de
potes moi qui m'ont dit on est parti
d'ailleurs là de Paris parce que il y a
trop de tension il y a trop de trucs on
pe plus les synages sont protégés he pas
les mieuxs bien il y a aussi un problème
d'antisémme ne confondez pas SR
terrorisme Sr c'est et non mais vous
vous confondez tout
là mais je vous le dis ça rien à voir
les mosquées je vous dis comme dit Gill
je je le ressens aussi en ce moment
c'est aussi dur je vous le dis c'est
c'est très dur par ce qui se passe
actuellement en Israël et pour toute la
communauté juive c'est non mais c'est
c'est un traumatisme énorme et en fait à
chaque fois aussi ce qui se passe c'est
que moi j'en ai marre de
voir des regards fillants un Gill on
sent que c'est c'est bizarre en ce
moment hein c'est bizarre c'est bizarre
moi j'aime pas ça j'aime pas cette
atmosphère je vous le dis moi j'ai que
des frères que ce soit des frères voilà
de de toutes les religions et tous mes
potes c'est mes frères voilà on se parle
pas de ça aujourd'hui il faut que vous
sachiez un truc qui est très grave c'est
que dans les sociétés aujourd'hui il est
interdit dans certaines sociétés de
parler des événements actuels parce
qu'ils ont peur que ça fasse des
embrouille les gars on on part on ça
part en couille moi quand je vois des
gens et qui me disent et ben aujourd'hui
euh moi je suis musulman il y a des
fuges dans mon dans dans ma société B on
se parle plus trop en ce moment euh
c'est bizarre les gars là on fait tout
ce qu'il faut pas faire là c'est
catastrophique je vous le dis c'est
catastrophique c'est vraiment tout ce
qu'on voulait pas entendre est en train
de se passer actuellement il y a plein
de gens qui et on le sens je suis désolé
les gars on le sens moi j'ai mes potes
musulmans ils me disent et ben je te dis
je sens un truc alors que je vous dis un
truc et je vous jure moi j'ai des pote
de en banlieu et vous savez en en
banlieu je suis désolé les gars pour
l'instant ça se passe très bien tant
mieux et je vous le dis ça se passe très
bien il y a des mecs qui passent en
quiipa devant des des des jeunes
musulmans ça se passe très bien ça va
vous avez des trucs je vous le dis et
j'ai les infos moi je de s San en tout
cas en S ça se passe très bien donc mais
ils sont pas rentrés dans dans ce truccl
là et il y a des il y a des on sent
aujourd'hui une tension alors que les
gars arrêtez on on il faut pas qu'on
rentre là-dedans sinon c'est
catastropique encore une fois moi moi je
peux je peux témoigner parce que je suis
un gamin de champign moi je suis un
gamin des B lieux je sais d'où je viens
je vous
assure c'est c'est encore une fois fois
c'est c'est les médias qu'il faut tout
gonfler moi champign ça se passe bien il
y a il y a une communauté juive il y a
une communauté sénégalaise il y a une
communauté capverdienne il y a des gens
du monde entier on a tous des potes
d'enfance on a tous été levé Paris
madame levy on a tous été mangé chez
Jonathan on a tous été mangé chez tout
le monde et il y a aucun souci
aujourd'hui je connais aucun juif ou
aucun ami c'est pas des amis c'est des
frères avec qui j'ai j'ai vécu au club
des années ou ou ici des années qui
m'ont dit ah on est content on a
fumé 3000 Palestiniens jamais de la vie
j'ai pas un pote jamais de la vie ils
on le cur blessé et ils savent pas où se
mettre il ils sont encore plus mal à
l'aise que moi bien parce qu'ils ont pas
de mot et et qui on est aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous est-ce qui on est pour
trouver la solution est-ce que vous
pensez que je je suis plus fort qu'un
Churchill qu'unener qu'un de GA qu'un
Picot que que je suis plus fort qu'un
Kissinger qu'un Nixon qu'un mitéran pour
trouver la solution ou même d'un Arafat
ou ou de qui vous voulez j'ai pas de
solution la seule solution c'est de
l'amour c'est de la paix c'est de
partager de comprendre et pas de menacer
vous voyez fait mal au cœur quand quand
je vois que toutes les personnes qui
sont ici qui viennent Tafer ils
reçoivent des menaces parce que ils ont
conjugué le mauvais le mauvais le
mauvais verbe qui qui ont dit la
mauvaise phrase qui ont pas répondu
comme il fallait et qui ont pas éé dans
le sens des des spectateurs ou ou de
leur lecteur mais c'est lamentable
d'être menacé pour ça menacé c'est mais
mais où on
vit mais c'est affreux moi j'ai vécu
pendant 30 ans dans une bulle moi je
suis un enfant des clubs j'arrive des
clubs de vacances pendant 30 ans j'ai
vécu avec des gens de toutes les
couleurs mél non mais ça ce qui se passe
actuellement je te dis c'est exactement
ce qu'on voulait pas et je Tu tous mes
potes musulmans qui me disent tous les
jours on s'appelle on se dit
c'est c'est c'est c'est compliqué euh en
ce moment et c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué je vous le dis c'est compliqué
parce que on sent une défiance on sent
on on voilà on sent un truc qui qui qui
qui est pas bon Bonot défiance he il y a
une défiance un truc voilà exactement
ouais ouais c'est pas bon c'est pas bon
moi moi je vais vous dire euh je le vois
moimême sur les réseaux là j'ai vu qu'il
y avait des mecs qui me disaient oui
parce que j'ai j'ai j'ai condamné
l'attentat
terroriste écoutez
et je le condamnerai à vitam etternam et
tout ce qui se passe je condamnerai et
la et je je le redis la position de la
la France insoumise je la condamnerai
quoi qu'il arrive pendant des années et
des années ce qu'ils ont fait est
inadmissible mais à cause de ça à cause
de ça il y a parfois des gens qui disent
ouais il faut boycotter l'émission de
cyila les gars ça je vous dire boycotter
ce que vous voulez les mecs qui veent
côté c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est ils
ont rien compris en fait ils ont rien
compris c'est c'est c'est un discours
contraire à la paix et je peux vous dire
qu'ici sur le plateau ce que vous êes et
et je vous dire qu'ici sur le plateau on
a été les plus justes je trouve de tout
les médias qui ont traité de cette
actualité les plus justes on a été
essayé d'être les les les plus factuels
poss possiblebl même si ici les gens
donnent leur avis et je vais vous dire
comme je vous l'ai dit la dernière fois
c'est pas pas parce que je suis juif et
que je suais juif toute ma vie c'est pas
pour ça que j'oublie les musulmans et
que j'ai jamais aidé les musulmans
combien de fois on m'a reproché aussi et
moi d'avoir des voilà de dire que Cyril
et ben il est il est toujours les mêmes
il est toujours les musulmans bah oui
mais j'aide tout le monde moi que ce
soit les juifs les musulmans les les les
les chrétiens j' tout le monde moi je
rentre pas là-dedans s'il y a quelqu'un
aidé je rentre pas là-dedans moi c'est
voilà je suis pas en train de me dire il
est quoi lui Ah bah non il est musulman
on va pas l'aider il est juif non on va
pas l'aider on n'est pas là-dedans et je
vais vous dire ici on est l'émission
plus ouverte et la plus orientale la
plus orientale du PA j'ai envie de dire
parce qu'il y a qu'ici que vous verrez
des mot en arabe il y a qu'ici que vous
verrez euh des des des des gens que vous
voyez sur aucun autre plateau et je vais
vous dire moi après tout ce que j'ai
fait euh toutes ces années et tous les
gens que j'ai aidé ça me fait de la
peine de voir des messages comme ça
parce que on est obligé je vous le dis
de condamner le terrorisme
ou qui soit on est d'accord bien sûr
mais donc on est d'accord dans ce que je
dis sur sur que j'ai et sur les messages
on peut avoir ou sur voilà c'est c'est
comme parfois je vois des gens qui s'en
prennent à Géraldine sachez-le Géraldine
elle est tous sauf raciste si Géraldine
était raciste elle serait pas avec moi
dans mes émissions parce que j'en veux
pas de ça Géraldine elle serait pas là
Géraldine a laissé Géraldine elle pas
parler là parce que ce serait pire
peut-être non mais non mais je te le dis
tu es pas géraline elle est pas raciste
géradine mais sinon tu serais pas avec
moi non mais je te le dis je vois des
beaucoup de messages qui disent oui
Géraldine elle est toujours par je suis
contre les attentats mais c'est
ça il y a qu' avoir même notre public
l're public comment il est la diversité
de notre public les les chroniqueuses
qui sont venus ici avec des voile on
nous a reproché pourquoi vous faites vir
des chroniqueuses avec des voil pourquoi
ceci pourquoi derrière là on voit en
gros plan il y a trois filles avec le
voile elles sont choquées pourquoi ceci
pourquoi cela et là maintenant on nous
dit carrément ah bah Vous vous vous
aimez pas les musulmans vous êtes
racistes s'il y avait 6 millions de
musulmans qui seraient terroristes le
pays sera déjà éclaté depuis longtemps
donc forcément qu'il y a des musulmans
comme il l'a dit Gill qui se lèv le
matin qui demand rien à person musulans
c'est la
majorité dis la majorité comme dans tout
y av 6 millions de mecs qui foutaient le
bordel je dire nous ici il y a pas de
différence voilà les seuls gens qu'on
veut pas c'est les cons voilà je vous
dis le reste et tout le monde est le
bienvenu sur le plateau et on essaiera
d'aider le plus possible tout le monde
et nous on est juste nous on a juste
envie de de de nous on n pas envie je
vous dis ça me fait pas plaisir de
traiter ces sujets sachez-le me frotte
pas les mains je le redis moi
aujourd'hui je viens dans cette émission
et je viens en direct parce que ça me
fait plaisir parce que c'est ça me fait
plaisir de vous voir tous les soirs ça
me fait plaisir parler au public ça me
fait plaisir de voir les gens dans le
public aujourd'hui je le dis et je pense
qu'ils peuvent le dire je pourrais
arrêter bien sûr dis moi c'est pas j'ai
pas j'ai pas j'ai pas besoin je viens
parce que ça me fait plaisir et parce
que je kiffe être avec vous et
aujourd'hui moi je préférerais qu'on
soit tous unis dans la paix et qu'on
fasse des rigolades ensemble plutôt que
de traiter de sujets comme ça sachez-le
quand je me réveille le matin je me dis
pas quel drame il y a eu je me dis
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire comme
rigolade je préfère avec les
téléspectateurs et public et qu'on
continue à rigoler ensemble voilà donc
je vous dis c'est pas c'est pas facile
c'est pas facile mais on essaie de de
faire le maximum sachez-le c'est pas
facile de traiter tous les sujets on
essaie de faire le maximum avec nos
moyens et on essaie de d'être le plus
juste possible voilà après personne
n'est parfait voilà et personne ne peut
avoir toujours raison voilà Galine je te
donnerai la parole dans un instant à
tout de suite